- A lot of people think that
models wear makeup all the time
but as a matter of fact,
when you go to the castings
or jobs people always ask you to
have absolutely no makeup on.
Today my makeup look
is a brown smokey eye,
a nude lip, and some shimmer on my cheeks.
- I'm wearing a natural, soft
look but with a strong brow.
- Cat eyes, couple shadow,
and metallic lipstick.
- I'm wearing a really
grungey, rock chic makeup,
really dark eye.
- Clean skin, bold brows, slight
contouring, and a bold lip.
- [Vasilisa] A lot of people, in fact,
think that we're not real people.
Also people don't realize
that there's a huge team
behind that picture.
It may be up to 20 people on set
and I'm just talking about photo shoot.
The show, could be a hundred,
so it's a big process and
it's not only up to me.
It's thanks to all these
people who are so talented.
So yeah, there is a big work behind
all of these pretty pictures.
- [Britt] A hard thing in
this industry is comparison
but really it can apply to everyone,
especially this day and
age with social media
being what it is, a lot of
girls get skinny shamed.
Some girls are naturally skinny.
You just have to remember
that everyone's different.
- [Maria] People always
think I'm so skinny and tall.
They think, like, I
don't have pimples, I do.
When I grow up, my mom says that
it's not makeup who makes you beautiful,
but what is inside.
From modeling, I start to learn English,
talking with people and
I enjoy every second.
- [Anastasiia] They all
thinking that modeling life,
you wearing all these amazing clothes,
champagne all the time.
For some of the girls, it's
like this but not for everyone.
You waking up around six,
seven o'clock in the morning.
You have to be at work already
and then you shooting all day and
then you going home.
Some of the girls are working out,
some of the girls just, you know,
like to spend their
time with the families.
Yeah, that's basically the daily honestly.
- [Anja] I don't feel beautiful everyday.
Sometimes I have bad skin days
when I travel a lot or work a lot.
Sometimes I have bad hair days and
I just wanna cuddle up
under my sheets and just
watch Netflix the whole day.
We have our own insecurities
and we're not perfect.
- [Vasilisa] Because of my work,
I have to stay in a certain
shape which is very slim,
you know, very fit but it's
not considered to be sexy.
In this society, what's
sexy is big boobs, big butt,
you know, some curves
but I don't have that
and sometimes I wanna have that
because I wanna feel sexy like
the other girls on the beach
but I'm just, like, this flat girl.
When I wanna feel sexy, it's
like putting on high heels.
I don't care what everybody thinks.
I'm the tallest in the building.
- [Britt] There's this one
quote that I always really love.
It's called "comparison
is the thief of joy."
And it's very true and
I think that took me
a little bit of time to realize
because it's really easy
to get down on yourself
being older than a lot of
the models who I work with.
Over time, you kind of just learn to
roll with the punches more,
but I think you have
to embrace who you are
and what you bring to the table
because I think that
will ultimately make you
a more successful and
happier model and person.
- [Maria] Finally I change my hairstyle
because I was wearing my
long hair with extensions.
Three years ago, the black
model use a lot of extension
to do these shows and to do the chops
so now I think the market is
more open to use your own hair.
They actually now, they love a lot so
that's why I changed
and show my natural hair
and everybody love it.
Now, I grow up and I know that
every kind of hair, they can be beautiful.
- [Anastasiia] In the beginning,
when the kids are young,
they can say a lot of things
but when they gonna grow up,
a lot of people will be
jealous that your red hair.
A lot of people will be so
jealous of your freckles.
Every different person, every
different shape of the face
requires a completely different makeup.
Like good makeup completely depend on
good makeup artist.
- [Anja] As a kid, I
always got made fun of
for being too tall, too skinny,
and I just wanted to fit
in and look the same.
I really hated my eyebrows because
they were so dark and so thick
but today, this is what's in right now
so it works perfectly for me.
Basically, all my friends in the industry
had similar experiences so I was so happy
when I first started
modeling to realize that
there were other people in the world
going through the same thing.
- Maybe when I'm done, you know, modeling
I'm just gonna sit on
the most sugary diet,
get some boobs and ass and just rock it.
(laughter)
- [Voiceover] That's good uh...
- Or some fake ones.